all right brady so i've got for you a
puzzle
it's about darts
uh it involves some higher dimensional
geometry um and a couple of the most
famous numbers in math
so i'll describe the game we want to hit
as many bullseyes as we can so right now
the bullseye is this tiny red thing but
that's too small we're going to start
with a giant bullseye that fills up the
entirety of the board i have a proper
compass so i'm going to go ahead and cut
out a piece just a piece of paper to
indicate our enlarged bull's eye
not the greatest circle i've ever drawn
all you do is you try to hit the
bullseye each time we hit it though
based on where our shot is the
bullseye's going to shrink
so it's going to get harder and harder
as we go you're not going to hit the
walleye i'm not that bad
oh okay oh my goodness hang on that's
amazing thank you very much that is
amazing and you're kind of rewarded for
a good shot so uh let me tell you what
the rule is for how we shrink it so step
one i'm gonna draw a line from the
center to where i hit and maybe through
the future i'm just going to call that
distance h
so that's the distance of my hit and
then what i'm going to do is draw a
chord of the circle that's perpendicular
to this line that's our chord and our
rule
is that the length of this cord is the
new diameter of the circle which in this
case because i had a good shot right the
shot was nice and close to the center
i'm rewarded by the fact that it's not
going to shrink that much
is the center of the new circle where
your dart hit or where the original
great question it's where the original
center was all right so i'll draw a new
circle where the original center was i
actually wish my shot was worse now
because this is kind of too close to the
edge i mean you can kind of see it's
it's barely smaller oh yeah so that's
just trimming that circle down a bit so
i'm just going to be giving it a little
trim this is like getting your hair cut
you know once every week or something
like that and presumably this means that
the next shot is going to be
similarly difficult
this is actually fascinating because
when i animate it then it's like oh boom
the computer does it and i'm not messing
with the physical dartboard in any way i
think i'll stick to the animated style
for the sake of illustration i'm going
to try to make this a worse shot
oh
okay
oh my goodness
so if i do the algorithm again like this
cord is a little bit shorter because we
trimmed off the edges right and so it'll
also be just a tiny bit smaller so we
kind of could run that again but let me
let me try to get a worse shot
you can't even do it bad enough
um yeah consistency is only a virtue if
you're not a screw-up
so this one's nice and far away from the
center
and i'm going to be punished more
because it's far away so we'll do the
same game we'll take this off we're
going to make some cuts
distance is h1 okay so it'll be a chord
of the big circle
perpendicular to that line
the chord defines the new diameter but
it's kind of easier to think of as half
the chord as defining the new radius
certainly if you're drawing with a
compass
so i'll set my new radius but this time
because i was closer to the edge of my
you know quote unquote bullseye that
chord ends up smaller so i'm punished
which means that the new bullseye
is meaningfully smaller
smaller bullseye play the same game i'm
going to set it up so that the center is
at the center of the board now i'm going
to actually try to hit closer to the
center because i want more shots for a
higher score
and i i didn't hit close to the center
oh dear you are going to get punished
for that so at this point maybe you can
already see how much that's going to
punish me the idea that it's close to
the edge means that the cord defining
the new radius
is going to be quite a bit smaller
[Music]
put it on the board now we see how good
you are so far i've hit three this is
for a fourth
all right i miss
oh dear
game over game over so what's so your
score for that game is three because you
hit three i hit three i will say that
would be the natural way to score it
based on what i want the answer to look
like at the end here you get one point
just for playing
okay so you get one point just for
playing and then one point for each
bullseye that you hit so in this case i
got a score of four you can say maybe
your uh what we're counting is how many
darts you throw in total so i threw four
darts and the fourth one happened to be
a miss whatever you want to do to
artificially add one you'll see why we
like that at the end all right so i've
defined a game i haven't defined the
puzzle yet and so for the puzzle let me
just draw our board again or at least
draw a circle all right so we're gonna
have a random darts player so he throws
at the board with some random
distribution
we all do but there's no skill here
there's no there is absolutely no
waiting for the skill it could it's as
likely to be anything this will be a
very bad in fact so he he throws it in a
weird way we're going to think of the
square that encompasses the board and
this is a little unrealistic because any
real dart player their distribution is
probably rotationally symmetric right i
mean why would it care about the
diagonal directions but basically he
hits it at a random point anywhere
within a square encompassing whatever
our first circle was okay so maybe you
imagine that the whole dartboard
is a square and then it'll be shrinking
within that that's my x coordinates
y and maybe let's say that this happens
to be
radius of one for the original circle
because why not the x coordinate for
this person is always going to be
something between negative one and one
and it'll just be completely uniform
within that
so this would be the simplest thing to
model on a computer to do it you just
choose two different numbers each one
between negative one and one where every
one of those is equally probable so
every point in this whole square is
equally probable and that square doesn't
shrink it's only the circle that shrinks
and the question is what's the expected
score okay so we want to know
the expected
score
for this uh thrower
so grant after you throw your first dart
and the circle shrinks the square
doesn't shrink with it it does not
shrink no so the the distribution for
the thrower is the same you might
imagine the dart board itself which is
fixed is square and the bullseye is
shrinking okay
because otherwise it's going to be the
same probability for each shot
and some viewers might be able to guess
what that probability is and it wouldn't
be as interesting a problem another way
to think about the expected score
imagine this random player plays a
thousand games right just what's his
average score for those thousand games
another way to think about it is you say
it's going to be the probability that
the score is equal to one
times one for that score
plus the probability because remember
the lowest score you can get is one
because you get that one point just for
playing the probability that the score
is equal to 2
times 2
plus the probability that the score is
equal to 3 times 3
and so on so what we need to figure out
is all of these probabilities in
principle you could have a perfect game
right if you hit in the center every
single time and it never shrinks you're
hitting a perfect game um what we'll
find is that that's there's a
probability of zero that you hit uh
bullseye infinitely many times but it's
also interesting how quickly does it
shrink would a score of 10 be absurd or
would that be maybe expected what is the
probability of getting an exact bullseye
because an exact bull's eye is like
presumably an infinitesimally small
point it's probability zero yeah right
so like one of those paradoxical facts
about probability is you can have events
that are possible it's just probability
zero right it's possible to hit an exact
bullseye it's just probability zero you
know if you choose a random number from
the number line it's possible that it's
rational but it's probability zero and
this a lot of people kind of try to come
to philosophical terms with like how can
it be possible but probability is zero
the probability would have to be
slightly bigger but it's uh just one of
those things of math
all right so anytime you're solving a
puzzle that's hard and this this is hard
you see if you can ask an easier version
of it or some easy sub problem within it
what's the easiest thing you can get a
foothold in right and maybe in this case
the easiest question to start that's not
totally trivial is what's the
probability of hitting
the first shot and this isn't that your
score is exactly equal to one if you hit
a first shot your score is greater than
or equal to one or no actually because
you do get that point for free this is
the probability that your score is
greater than one actually maybe you can
tell me right what's the probability
that on this first shot with this random
distribution within the square it hits
somewhere inside this whole circle i'm
imagining we need the area of the circle
and the area of the square yep the area
of the circle this is pi r squared and
that radius starts off as 1 so that ends
up just being pi and the area of the
square is equal to well the square side
length is 2 times that radius right so
it's 2 by 2 so it's 4
which means the probability that you hit
um that first bullseye that your score
will be greater than one because you get
that one point free just for playing
is going to be
the area of that circle divided by the
area of that square what happens if the
dart lands on the line
that's probability zero
don't worry about it it won't mess with
the problem so now a much a much harder
question is okay you've hit that first
shot what's the probability that you hit
at least two and this is where it starts
to become interesting because this
depends on where your first shot was i'm
going to start writing a little bit of a
chart where i'm going to keep track of
the radius of each bullseye and i'm
going to keep track of just the hit
length at each point and so the radius
starts off as one
and that first hit
it's a it's a random point let's just
give it a name for now
let's say it goes there
that's h0
this will be h0
and
by the pythagorean theorem
if we want to describe what this is in
terms of x and y which will be helpful
for later on to be thinking of it in
terms of that
it's the square root
of x squared
plus y squared if those are the
coordinates of your first shot and
because we're going to have other shots
i'm also going to give these guys a
subscript so now it's a geometry
question to ask what's the new radius
maybe we call this our zeroth radius
right and i wanna know what's the next
radius after that
initial shot
and if we remember our rule we say
you draw the chord
and the chord was defined to be
perpendicular to that so when you know
that it's defined to be perpendicular
you know that you're probably going to
use that fact in your solution to the
puzzle
so the new radius is this length here
right it's half of that chord so what we
might do
and i recognize i'll sort of be drawing
over myself a bit here
because we have a right triangle here
and that's what defined it we're going
to use pythag the pythagorean theorem
because this was our old radius radius 1
that's the new hypotenuse so we know
that
the old hypotenuse 1 squared is equal to
one of the legs which was h
naught squared
plus the new radius squared
plus
r1
squared so what that means for what r1
is
is it's the
square root of one squared minus h
naught squared and remember the only way
that you're even getting to this point
is this h naught was less than one if
you got that first one in the bullseye
so this will be nice and well defined no
imaginary numbers or anything like that
similarly now we're going to have a new
shot
it's determined by two new random
coordinates whatever the coordinates of
your second shot
happen to be or the coordinates of the
next shot maybe i should say and this is
an interesting question what's the
probability that you get that second one
in because it depends on four different
numbers right
so i think it's helpful to just write
out what the what the actual requirement
is h1 the hit in that second shot is
less than r1 and i can go ahead and
rewrite that by saying
h1 squared is less than r1 squared and
the reason is we have a whole bunch of
squares going on maybe that's going to
be helpful for us right because i can
expand out what h1 squared is
that's x1 squared plus
y1 squared
and that has to be less than well what
is r1 squared
well that's 1 squared
minus
h naught squared and then i can also
expand out h naught
so i'll be writing this as x 1 squared
plus y 1 squared
is less than 1 squared minus
x not squared
plus y not
squared so all i'm doing is saying i
want to explicitly write out what the
requirement is for the four coordinates
of my initial random shot
and now i have a bit of an interesting
question i might rearrange this so that
all of my x's and y's are on one side
and the one is just on the other what i
have is that x naught squared
plus y naught squared you know bringing
these two over to the other side
plus
x one squared plus y1 squared
is less than 1. what's the probability
that this happens
when all these four numbers were chosen
randomly within the range negative one
to one so at this point that's kind of a
hard question right i tell you
choose four random numbers we're gonna
add up their squares what's the
probability that they're less than one
and you think to yourself oh i don't
know you know if they were all less than
0.5 i guess that would happen uh but if
one of them was 0.9 that doesn't throw
everything off because the others could
be quite small and to think about this
let's just think about the very first
situation where instead of doing it for
h1 and r1
when we're over here doing it for what
seemed like a much simpler situation and
it was the probability that h naught is
less than r naught which is just saying
that x naught squared
plus y naught squared is less than one
we have a purely analytic statement
choose two numbers out of a hat based on
this rule what's the probability that
the sum of their squares is less than
one you answered it geometrically you
immediately knew oh we need to use pi
we're thinking of the area of the circle
right
and it's actually quite subtle what's
happening there you have a question
about a pair of numbers and you're
gaining intuition and using facts that
we've discovered in math like the area
of a circle by thinking of that not as
two separate entities but as a single
point in two-dimensional space that
might sound obvious the reason i'm
hampering down on it is look at what we
have over here four separate numbers
what you're asking for is a
probabilistic property of these four
numbers
it might be natural to think of them as
being
a single point
x naught
y naught
x one
y one
inside
four-dimensional space
right it's basically a space that has
four real number coordinates and so now
brady let me ask you what's the
analogous question in the same way that
asking what's the probability that the
sum of two random numbers is less than
one
begs the question of what the area of a
circle is
when we ask what's the probability that
the sum of four
squares is less than one
what do you want to know well i was
hoping we were going to end up using
a cube and a sphere but i feel like
we've jumped up we've jumped we've
jumped the whole idea that hey if i
choose three random numbers x squared y
squared z squared
um what's the probability that they're
less than one if they're chosen by the
same rule what you're going to be asking
for is the volume of a sphere because
what it means for the sum of their
squares to be less than one is that they
sit inside a unit sphere
the volume of a sphere
is four thirds
pi
r cubed r is just going to equal one so
that's four thirds pi that's the
volume of a sphere the volume of the
cube
which is two by two by two
is going to be two cubed
which is eight so if we were asking an
analogous question where three
dimensions happened to pop up you would
just divide these two numbers you would
have four thirds pi divided by eight
which would be pi sixths you'll see it's
actually quite helpful that we're going
to skip over odd-numbered dimensions
here and so here we went straight from
two to four
the question that we want to ask right
now is what's the volume of a
four-dimensional sphere or the
four-dimensional equivalent of volume
instead of saying hyper-volume or coming
up with a new word they just say volume
you could fancifully say measure but
we're just going to say volume
of a 4d
sphere and again if you wanted to be
pedantic a mathematician might actually
say ball because when they use the word
sphere they typically refer to the
boundary right it's just the peel of the
orange it's not the contents of the
orange so what we really want is the
ball the other thing that we need is the
volume of a 40 cube the cube is the easy
one just like in the other cases the
side lengths are all two two by two by
two
by two
so that volume is 16. volume of the
sphere there's a whole interesting
discussion that we could have about the
volumes of higher dimensional spheres
the surface areas or the analogs of
surface areas of higher dimensional
spheres and where they come from
i'm not going to give you that full
story now maybe at some other point it
happens to be the case that it is pi
squared halves times r to the fourth so
it picks up an extra pi which is kind of
interesting when you go from two to
three you don't pick up that pie but
when you go from three to four you pick
up that extra pie and because our radius
is one in this case that'll just be
pie squared halves and let's remember
what this is this isn't the probability
of hitting exactly two shots right it's
that you hit those first two shots so
it's the probability that your score is
at least two maybe it also happens to be
three or four so we can write our answer
here the probability that our score is
greater than or equal to two is equal to
pi squared and i'm going to actually
write it as being over like the 16 as
two to the fourth just to remember where
it came from
so this was kind of the uh the cube or
the hypercube and then times two where
that was the denominator that we had
from our volume of the 4d ball and now
we just keep doing this for all
infinitely many different scores that we
might have very similarly when we're
asking about the probability that our
score
is at least three or that it's bigger
than three what this comes down to is
asking we're going to have six different
coordinates x naught y naught
x one
y one x two y two
and that the sum of their squares
is less than one
[Music]
i don't know how to calculate the volume
of a six dimensional bowl no
luckily mathematicians have figured it
out for us and again it could be a whole
interesting story but if you go to
wikipedia you could see a chart there's
quite a nice pattern that we're about to
point out for where that comes from
but the volume of a 6d ball happens to
be pi cubed over 6
times
r to the sixth and then the volume of
the 60 cubed is of course 2 to the sixth
and so the answer to the probability of
hitting those first three shots is gonna
be pi cubed
divided by that two to the sixth and
then what its denominator was which was
the six because that r ends up being one
and now i'll tell you the more general
fact
which is pretty mind-blowing is that the
volume of a 2n
ball is equal to
pi to the n so half of the dimension
right so in two dimensions you see a pi
in four dimensions you see a pi squared
and six you see pi cubed so pi to half
the number of dimensions divided by n
factorial very clean very beautiful
very reminiscent of another celebrity
real number that a couple people might
be familiar with now and that might be
poking in their minds but if it's not
we'll get to it in just a moment given
this as a fact that we'll just hand down
from on high
let's figure out the expected score
please that's what i'm here for
great
um first let me get a cup of water
all right are you ready for the grand
finale yeah the finishing touch it seems
like it'll be chaotic but it'll collapse
in the most wonderful of ways so the
expected score expected score
and remember what this means we're going
to have it's going to be 1 times the
probability that your score is 1
plus 2
times the probability that your score is
2
plus 3
times the probability that your score is
3. and so on
now all of our expressions are greater
than things they're not saying exactly
equal to but that's completely fine
because if i wanted to say for example
what's the probability that your score
is precisely equal to 2 so this will be
your probability that your score is
greater than one
right
minus the probability that the score
is greater than two
because for it to equal to it's greater
than one but it's not greater than two
and this entirely encompasses the
possibilities right if you're probably
if you get a score of greater than one
that encompasses all the possibilities
of getting a score greater than two so
it's okay to just subtract this off we
don't have to um do anything more than
that
so i'm going to expand all of these out
just a little bit before things collapse
nicely
so this will be 1
times
the
probability that the score is bigger
than 0
minus
probability of the score
is bigger than one
plus two
times the probability that the score is
bigger than one
minus the probability that the score is
bigger than two and just one more for
good measure
probability that the score is bigger
than two
minus
the probability of the score is bigger
than three so at this point we have a
lot of cancellation that happens so
we've got this probability that your
score is bigger than zero that just
stays on its own
for the probability that it's bigger
than one we're subtracting one here but
then we're adding two of them over here
so we've got
probability that the score is greater
than one and then similarly for score
bigger than two we're subtracting two
here
but we're adding three back here and so
we're just going to be adding
probability for the score is bigger than
two and in general all we're doing is
adding up all of the numbers that we
just saw all of those fun things
involving pi because with the 3 we're
subtracting 3 but in the next one we'll
be adding 4 and so on
so every puzzle that we just had every
micro puzzle we just add up all of their
answers
[Music]
so the probability that your score is at
least zero that's one definitely your
score is bigger than zero because you
get a point just for playing probability
that it's bigger than one that's the one
that you answered for me first which was
saying that it's pi divided by 4. the
next one so i'm actually going to write
this slightly differently because we
always have some power of pi divided by
some power of 2.
i'm going to write this as being
pi
4
squared
divided by 2.
is that all right so that 4 squared came
from that's the same as 2 to the fourth
and then the pi squared just went in
there and so i'm going to write it here
as
pi
fourths
squared
times one over two and then the next one
we had uh up here
and again i'm going to write it in terms
of pi fourths
rather than writing pi cubed over two to
the sixth which is the same as pi cubed
over four cubed
i'm going to write it as pi over four
cubed
and six
is really three factorial like the
reason that we see the two and then the
six is coming from this general pattern
of having a factorial so over here we've
got
pi
over 4
cubed times 1 over 3 factorial this is
really 2 factorial
and maybe you see where this is going or
maybe at this point you're saying you
promised me this would look simple it
actually looks exceedingly complicated
you've got factorials you're grouping
the pies together for some reason so
there's some viewers right now
especially if they're maybe a little bit
fresh off of a calculus class or if
they're particularly ingratiated to the
number e who just see something
screaming in their head right now
there's something known as the taylor
series for e to the x
which is that it's
one
plus
x and i'll write it as x to the one over
one factorial
x squared over two
factorial x cubed over 3 factorial
and so on
where
you evaluate it as an infinite
polynomial
where each one of the terms is 1 over n
factorial it's not just that e to the x
happens to equal this i actually think
the healthier way to view the
exponential function and what e to the x
is this defines it right this is the
thing that should pop into your head
when you think of exponential growth in
e to the x is this particular infinite
series this particular polynomial this
is where it will come up especially in
probability it lends itself to an easier
interpretation of why it is its own
derivative there's all sorts of nice
things uh it extends it makes it easier
to understand things like e to the pi i
all of that this is the healthy way to
think of e to the x so if you looked at
this and you weren't thinking of e
already
what it means is that there is a
healthier relationship with e waiting
for you in the future or if you didn't
say it you have an unhealthy
relationship you currently have an
unhealthy relationship with e that's
absolutely true um if you didn't see it
or or you have no relationship with e
but if we compare this to the series
which i've unhelpfully drawn kind of far
away we can match them up pretty easily
the thing that's playing the role of x
right now is pi fourths
so all this is
is e
to the pi fourths which if we go and we
plug it into a calculator approximately
equals two
point
one nine
three
2
on and on
which is to say
if you are a terrible random darts
player who unrealistically hits within a
square with a uniform probability which
you wouldn't because it would be
rotationally symmetric but whatever
you're hitting within a square
and you keep going like this and you
play a thousand games on average your
score would be 2.1932
and remember my score was four
um so you're you're not quite twice as
good as someone who has absolutely no
skill whatsoever
i i couldn't ask for a better
recommendation
uh yeah that's
uh that's about right
so there's a couple things i like about
this puzzle right the reason that i want
to relay it hopefully what was the more
i don't know unexpected or mind-blowing
component is that we're even talking
about higher dimensional geometry you
found yourself naturally asking in the
middle what is the volume of a
six-dimensional ball right
and nowhere in that was asking is the
universe six-dimensional like does
string theory invoke sixteen no no like
that's not why mathematicians
necessarily care about higher dimensions
what was happening is you had six
numbers
and you were encoding a property of
those six numbers with something that we
like to describe geometrically rather
than saying the sum of their squares is
less than one you say it shows up inside
a six dimensional ball
that also means it saved you some work
i put out this question to like some
channel supporters as an early teaser of
things and one of them got back to me
saying you know i've been working on it
and it's just like really hard i've been
like working through these integrals
what's very strange is even in the case
with the second dart i'm getting pi
squared for some reason so he's working
through all these integrals
under the hood what's happening is he's
rediscovering the volume of a
four-dimensional ball right so it gives
a more universal language for people to
talk with on that it came about from
two-dimensional geometry nothing about
the dartboard is four-dimensional and i
think this is just a common
misconception that people listening to
mathematicians describe things like
manifolds in four dimensions or the
poincare conjecture has been answered
for everything except four dimensions
they don't actually care about like a
thing where you can move in four
dimensions it's about encoding
quadruplets of points
and the second one is that i think it
helps build a healthier relationship
with e because this the series is much
more important than the number itself i
i might i might even just ask the puzzle
and then we won't answer it but it's a
good thing to end on yeah um so here we
were choosing these random numbers
between negative one and one and what
were we asked what we were asking is
something about when you sum their
squares uh when is that less than one
you can play a much simpler probability
game where let's say i'm just going to
choose numbers
from zero to one with uniform
probability and i'm going to keep going
until the sum
of the numbers that i've chosen ends up
being bigger than 1.
so for example if the first number you
choose is 0.3 and then the second one is
0.6 their sum is 0.9 and if the next one
you choose is 0.5 that's the point when
you go over and so the question you can
ask is what's the expected number of
samples you need to take before it
overblows one e shows up in the answer
right and the way it shows up is
actually quite similar here and it's a
way that's distilled because it doesn't
involve circles so there's not the
confusing factor of pi you see much more
pristinely the factorials very important
is that i mentioned where this puzzle
comes from i saw this on twitter i think
it was greg egan he specifically
designed a puzzle such that the answer
would look like adding up the volumes of
higher dimensional balls because we have
this wonderful formula for the volume of
higher dimensional balls when the number
of dimensions is even and everyone who
has a healthy relationship with e looks
at this a thing to the power n divided
by n factorial they stream in their mind
the exponential function with e to the x
right and it it sort of asks you to add
them which is a weird thing to do why
would you do that it's very strange what
is how do you even interpret the sum of
the area of a circle to the volume of a
four-dimensional sphere uh so he
specifically designed a puzzle such that
this would be the answer which i think
is beautiful and clever
here's a very interesting thing we're
adding up all of these volumes right it
converges and what that means is that
higher and higher out the volume of a
high dimensional sphere is quite small
right in fact we could compute it out if
if i said hey what's the volume of a 100
dimensional ball
well that would be pi
to the 50th
divided by 50 factorial well the thing
is with with 50 factorial the numbers
you're multiplying in it's 1 times 2
times 3 times 4 times 5 times 6 you're
you're multiplying bigger and bigger
numbers pi to the 50 you're always
multiplying a pi right so the
denominator starts winning out because
by the end you've added an extra pi to
the top but an extra 50 to the bottom so
it shrinks by quite a lot around uh
2.368 times 10 to the negative 40th
if you think about what that means if
you're in 100 dimensions right and you
look at a 100 dimensional cube and you
say let's look at the sphere that's
touching every single edge of that cube
what proportion of the square does that
sphere occupy
it's it's around 10 to the negative 40th
right
a lot of people find that quite
counterintuitive right because if you
think of a two-dimensional circle it
feels like most of the square or
three-dimensional sphere it fills up
most of the cube
but if you think of what it's actually
asking
are you doing what you just told people
off for doing though and imagining these
as real spaces rather than well they are
so sorry when i say real i mean they're
exactly as real as numbers are right
like the real number line you're not
going to find that in nature you're not
hiking through the woods and there's the
real number line
so in the same way like 100 dimensional
space it's a useful abstraction
what i would suggest people not hinge on
is asking is the universe 100
dimensional and is the only way that
it's meaningful to ask questions about
100 dimensions
if the universe has that wiggle room but
people find this quite counterintuitive
how small
in a sense small balls are up in higher
dimensions but if you interpret it much
more literally by saying choose 100
numbers okay all of them chosen
uniformly between negative one and one
add up their squares what's the
probability that the sum of all those
squares is less than one it's like oh we
got a hundred of them of course this can
be bigger than one there's just so many
numbers right same thing that's going on
there's so many dimensions um so this is
why it's helpful to have a back and
forth between analytic thinking and
geometric thinking
[Music]
if you haven't already make sure you
check out grant's incredible math
channel three blue one brown
and if you'd like to hear more from
grunt on the numberphile podcast check
out the links on the screen and down in
the video description
[Music]